zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live mit ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen diskussionen und ereignissen
morgen will sich die bundesregierung ja
wieder wird den ministerpräsidentinnen
der bundesländer zusammen setzen um den
neuen corona maßnahmen zu besprechen und
zu beschließen
und ganz aktuell kam da gerade die
meldung kurz vor der sendung das wohl
bundesweit die weihnachtsferien
vorgezogen werden sollen auf den 16
dezember also nicht wie sonst üblich
kurz vor heiligabend sondern tatsächlich
ein paar tage früher der hintergrund
scheint zu sein dass die
verantwortlichen hoffen dass dann die
infektionszahlen vielleicht wieder
runter gehen weil es weniger kontakte
gibt
bis dahin soll aber der
präsenzunterricht so lange wie möglich
aufrechterhalten werden die masken
pflicht ist aber auch eine maßnahme die
diskutiert wird und zwar eine
ausgeweitete maßen pflicht dass man geht
ja vor allem in den pausen und auf dem
schulhof jetzt wird auch diskutiert dass
im unterricht die masten zu tragen sind
manche bundesländer machen das schon ab
klasse 7 jetzt soll es überall kommen
dort wo es diesen berühmten instituts
wert von 50 fällen auf 100000 einwohner
innerhalb von sieben tagen gibt und das
ist wenn man auf die karte guckt fast
bundesweit der fall 370 landkreise etwa
sind betroffen von 400 in deutschland
mit ausnahme der grundschulen sollten
dann da wahrscheinlich bald auch massen
im unterricht getragen werden die
bundesländer können außerdem entscheiden
so jetzt zumindest die beschlussvorlage
ob die klassen geteilt werden soll dann
ist nix geht's aus präsenzunterricht und
online unterricht der präsenzunterricht
könnte außerdem gestaffelt beginnen das
ist eine andere idee also die
schülerinnen sollen dann nacheinander in
die schule kommen um zum beispiel so die
schulbusse zu entlasten
die große frage ist aber reichen diese
maßnahmen die dort angedacht werden und
sind die kinder und jugendlichen
tatsächlich so gefährlich wie erwachsene
was die infektionsgefahr angeht sind sie
quasi treiber der infektion weil der
unterricht in den schulen ganz normal
derzeit weiter geht mit vielen menschen
auf engem raum oder ist das ganze
vielleicht doch
ganz so schlimm das wollen wir heute
diskutieren mit der virologen und
epidemiologin doktor corinna pietsch von
der uni leipzig und ihren fragen in
kommentaren wie immer gerne in die dafür
vorgesehenen spalten oder an diese e
mail adresse hier zdf heute.de zdf.de
aber bevor wir in die diskussion
einsteigen gucken wir uns doch erstmal
das zahlenmaterial an und das sieht
folgendermaßen aus die zahlen sind
nämlich in den letzten wochen deutlich
gestiegen anfang oktober gab es 33 fälle
pro 100.000 in der gruppe der ältesten
und jetzt mit dem november haben wir
schon 218 fälle pro 100.000 das heißt
das sind ein deutlicher sieg nach oben
und da fragen wir doch gleich mal die
philologin doktor corinna pietsch von
der uni leipzig hallo
sie können mich hören und sehen hören
kann ich kann sie haben einen schönen
guten abend wundervoll sind das jetzt
zahlen die quasi parallel zu den
infektionszahlen der erwachsenen zu
betrachten sind oder gibt es da doch
irgendwo einen signifikanten unterschied
nein alles in allem ist das doch ganz
ähnlich zu dem was wir auch bei den
erwachsenen sehen wir haben auch bei den
kindern gesehen dass wir in den
sommermonaten in den ferien natürlich
weniger infektionen hatten und jetzt wo
in der bevölkerung insgesamt die fälle
mehr werden wird es natürlich auch
analog mehr
bei den personen in dem alter in dem man
zur schule geht also bei diesen 0 bis 9
jährigen und auch bei den neun bis 19
jährigen sehen wir jetzt auch eine
zunahme von den fällen wir haben
insgesamt bei den ganz kleinen schülern
also die in dieser altersgruppe null bis
neun fallen würden haben wir ein paar
weniger relativ gesehen als in der
restbevölkerung aber ich denke das wird
sich auch in den nächsten tagen oder
wochen relativieren
am anfang der pandemie wurde ja doch
viel diskutiert darüber wie schlimm
quasi oder wie groß die infektionsgefahr
von kindern und jugendlichen ist gerade
was die gruppen der älteren angeht
dann wurde gesagt das ganze ist nicht so
schlimm was es denn dass ihrer
einschätzung haben wir die schulen als
infektionsträger da unterschätzt
ich glaube die schulen sind weder
infektions treiber oder treiber der
pandemie noch sind sie irgendein hort wo
überhaupt gar keine infektion vorkommen
würden sondern sie bilden genau das
gleiche ab was wir auch sonst in der
bevölkerung sehen immer da wo viele
menschen auf engem raum in geschlossenen
räumen sind finden natürlich auch
infektionen stadt das ist in einem
großraumbüro ganz genauso wie in der
klasse und von daher schätze ich sie
ganz genauso gefährdet wie auch andere
personen und auch ganz genau so sind sie
natürlich hin und wieder auch quelle von
infektionen
jetzt haben wir ja gerade gehört dass er
ein wirklich eine eilmeldung kurz bevor
wir angefangen haben mit der sendung
dass in der erneuerten oder in der
aktualisierten beschlussvorlage die
morgen diskutiert wird zwischen
bundesregierung und den bundesländern
eine einheitliche weihnachtsferien
beginnen ab dem 16 12 kommen soll das
betrifft natürlich jetzt sehr viele
menschen da draußen sehr viele familien
die vielleicht auch überlegen müssen was
jetzt mit den kindern machen sie keine
wahl keinen keine ferien eingereicht
haben ist denn das tatsächlich jetzt
eine maßnahme wie sie sagen würden ja
damit können wir zumindest versuchen
über weihnachten weniger infektionen zu
haben damit wir ein einigermaßen
normales weihnachtsfest kriegen also ich
glaube das hat ja vermutlich zwei
hintergründe warum man sich dazu
entschlossen hat das eine ist
tatsächlich zu sagen okay es gibt dann
zu einem früheren zeitpunkt nicht mehr
diese mengen an schülern in engen räumen
und da gibt es dann vielleicht keine
übertragung mehr
aber ich glaube steckt auch dahinter
dass man den familien die möglichkeit
geben möchte wird als wäre das will dass
man sagt man begibt sich einige tage
eben vor den vor der weihnachtszeit
schon mal ins emirat selbst quarantäne
zu hause vermeidet jegliche kontakte um
dann relativ sicher in die tatsächlichen
weihnachtsfeiertage gehen zu können und
dort zu sagen jetzt sind wir sicher wir
sind nicht infiziert wir hatten keine
kontakte in den letzten tagen und wochen
vielleicht sogar und können jetzt auch
dann in ruhe oma und opa oder ähnliche
einladen ohne irgendwie ein schlechtes
gewissen dabei zu haben ich denke es ist
geht in beide richtungen das was sie
sagen
in richtung betreuung natürlich dass es
immer das große problem wenn es darum
geht kitas und schulen zu schließen vor
allem den grundschulen auch zu schließen
wer betreut
diese kinder aber da muss ich sagen habe
ich jetzt noch keine information
inwieweit nicht dann doch auch
notbetreuung oder ähnliches möglich sein
werden für die eltern die dann eben
nicht kurzfristig das möglich machen
können die kinder selbst zu betreuen ja
muss ich auch sagen haben wir hier noch
nicht weil das kann eben gerade erst
kurz vor sendungsbeginn rein
vielleicht erfahren wir dann morgen mehr
wenn sich die regierungen
zusammengesetzt haben aber dass man bei
dieser weihnachtsferien geschichte kurz
geblieben ich habe mich dann gefragt ok
alle gehen früher in weihnachtsferien
das ist vielleicht auch manche dann kann
man noch mal schön shoppen gehen nochmal
weihnachtsgeschenke kaufen gehen dann
könnten sich wieder alle in den
supermärkten und in den kaufhäusern
das ist dann doch nicht so richtig ziel
oder nein mit sicherheit nicht aber es
ist ja so wie eigentlich schon die ganze
zeit in dieser pandemie wir haben das
auch selbst in unserer hand und wir
haben da auch selbst die verantwortung
und müssen damit eben entsprechend
verantwortungsvoll auch umgehen mit
diesen möglichkeiten die uns an die hand
gegeben werden und wenn uns die
möglichkeit gegeben wird wenig kontakte
zu haben weil wir beispielsweise keine
schulpflicht anhaben weil ferien sind
dann müssen wir das auch gut nutzen und
nicht so nutzen dass wir dann noch mehr
leute treffen so ich habe gerade wir
schauen noch einmal in die kommentare
schon einen kommentar von katja janke
auf facebook die schreibt so ein
blödsinn die inkubationszeit leid doch
und die ist ja eben bei einer kurve zwei
relativ lange oder frau doktor feature
ja die kann im einzelfall auch mal 14
tage wohl betragen aber im regelfall ist
jedoch deutlich kürzer und wenn wir
jetzt von dem 16 dezember reden und dann
sagen wir gehen woche bis zehn tage
hinten ran bevor wir dann die großeltern
treffen denke ich dass das schon ganz
vernünftiger zeitrahmen ist mit dem man
viel anfangen kann
so jetzt wollen wir einmal auf die
faktenlage gucken zumindest auf die
studienlage besser gesagt weil da wird
ja doch viel geforscht aber es gibt auch
unterschiedliche erkenntnisse es ist ein
großes kuddelmuddel hat mir mein kollege
tomas gonzalez
heute.at auftrag bekommen hat von uns
doch mal zu gucken wie es denn aussieht
der hat ein bisschen verzweifelt mit den
augen gerollt
aber dann uns folgendes hier abgeliefert
kinder und jugendliche sind
wahrscheinlich genauso infektiös wie
erwachsene
so jedenfalls der virologe christian
drosten ähnlich das robert koch institut
das betont aber die forschungen dazu
laufen noch nicht letztgültig geklärt
auch das haben sich mehr junge menschen
infiziert als bekannt ja sagt das
helmholtz zentrum münchen das testete
auf antikörper ergebnis einer stichprobe
bei 12.000 1 bis 18 jahre alten
probanden infiziert sind oder waren
sechs mal mehr als gemeldet fazit es
gibt eine hohe dunkelziffer zu einem
anderen resultat kommt eine neue studie
von kinder- und jugendmediziner sie
testeten 116.000 minderjährige jeden
alters aber nicht auf antikörper sondern
auf das virus selbst und stellten keine
dunkelziffer fest außerdem nur 8 von 600
infizierten steckten sich in der schule
an die meisten außerhalb weil sie dort
kaum masken tragen kaum abstände
einhalten gibt es an schulen also nur
ein geringes risiko
nein in die schule gehen das kann sehr
wohl ansteckungen vorantreiben sagt die
technische uni aachen
wenn 35 schüler in einem klassenraum
sind und der schlecht belüftet ist dann
kann das infektionsrisiko 12 fach erhöht
sein
was ist denn ihre schlussfolgerungen aus
diesen verschiedenen studien studien
ganz unterschiedliche personengruppen
untersucht haben zu ganz
unterschiedlichen zeiten mit
unterschiedlichen methoden und deshalb
kommt man eben auch zu unterschiedlichen
ergebnissen ist mir schon klar dass das
verwirrt also ich würde auch dem
zustimmen zu sagen
insgesamt betrachtet sind kinder aus
meiner sicht genau so infektiös wie auch
die erwachsenen und bei den
verschiedenen studien die jetzt
sozusagen an schulen untersucht haben
oder schüler untersucht haben inwieweit
dort infektionsfälle aufgetreten sind
muss man immer im hinterkopf behalten
dass die daten die wir jetzt bekommen
aus diesen studien die stamm in der
regel eben aus untersuchungen die
entweder im frühjahr gelaufen sind als
der lock down war in den schulen oder
aus der zeit danach als wir eben noch
davon profitiert haben dass davor der
lock down war oder es waren sogar ferien
für die schüler
und da haben natürlich wenig kontakte
zum ein stattgefunden und insgesamt gab
es in der bevölkerung eine sehr niedrige
grund inzidenz von fällen das alles
führt natürlich dazu dass man so wie in
der gesamtbevölkerung auch zu dem
zeitpunkt sehr sehr wenige fälle bei den
schülern gefunden hat anders denke ich
sieht das aus wenn wir ab jetzt
untersuchen wir finden unser
epidemiologisch in einer ganz anderen
situation wir haben jetzt eben wie sie
auch schon sagten in mehr als 300
landkreisen einfach eine ganz hohe
inzidenz von saas corona virus und das
spiegelt sich dann eben auch bei den
schülern wieder aber das und das sehen
wir wenn wir jetzt einfach augen
das habe eine frage von peach warum hat
man aber warum gibt es nicht so ich
mache also eine große studie die
bundesweit geleitet wird über die
verschiedenen landkreise hinweg wo es
ein großes bild gibt wir kriegen immer
nur so kleine spots
da hat sich gestern der infektiologe
professor schlappe hier bei uns im live
stream auch sehr darüber ausgelassen der
das ganz scharf kritisiert und gesagt
hat also die zahlen die wir hier
bekommen sind im endeffekt überhaupt
nichts wert weil wir kennen die
dunkelziffer nicht und es ist alles
irgendwie sehr gut gelöst schließen sie
sich dieser kritik an bräuchten wir
nicht irgendwie bundesweit durchgeführte
studien zb vom rk ii
es ist natürlich ist es so dass wenn man
eine große datenmenge hat die man
auswertet dass man da in der regel eben
dann auch präzisere aussagen treffen
kann am ende es ist aber natürlich auch
nicht ohne aufwand das ganze
hinzubekommen und man muss sich auch
fragen wenn ich jetzt also bundesweit in
detail sagen wir jede schulklasse
untersuchen wollen würde was das nicht
nur für ein logistischer aufwand wäre
sondern was ich da auch an ressourcen
verbrauchen würde um diese testung zu
machen also man muss sich genau
überlegen wie das die frage natürlich
wäre das schön wenn wir die daten hätten
aber ich glaube die labors könnten sowas
ja auch gar nicht leisten aktuell wir
sind ja in der situation dass wir schon
gucken wen wir überhaupt mit pcr test
aktuell testen weil wir sehen dass
weltweit auf dem markt einfach bestimmte
dinge die wir hier im labor brauchen gar
nicht verfügbar sind unter nützt uns
nichts wenn wir sozusagen guten mutes
und guter ideen sind was wir alles gerne
noch testen möchten wenn wir am ende die
plastik waren die pipetten spitzentiere
ergänzen die wir brauchen um das zu tun
gar nicht bekommen so ich schaue jetzt
mal hier bei uns in die kommentare weil
da wird wieder munter diskutiert hier
geht es einmal einen anmerkung folgen
del barrio auf youtube kinder wurden
werden doch kaum getestet lediglich
infekte werden bestätigt mich wundern
niedrige infektionszahlen bei kindern so
gar nicht ist es eine richtige aussage
frau dr
ich denke auch dass das mit reinspielt
dass man generell zurückhaltend da ist
die kinder zu testen
wir haben das alle denke ich inzwischen
gehört diese nasen oder rachenabstrich
das ist nicht besonders angenehm das ist
auch für erwachsene ich angenehm für
kinder schon gar nicht unter überlegt
man sich das vielleicht doppelt so oft
ob man die überhaupt testen möchte das
wird sicherlich auch mit reinspielen
warum man da weniger positive tests am
ende hat weil wir einfach die ganz
kleinen kinder wahrscheinlich auch nicht
ganz so häufig testen
hier ist gibt es außerdem viel
unverständnis in den kommentaren darüber
dass überall quasi weniger kontakte da
sein sollen also ich kann das auch hier
zum beispiel fürs zdf sagen wir
versuchen wenige leute in den räumen zu
haben wir sind hier nicht in voller
besetzung
die kollegen müssen ausgegliedert werden
quasi in dunkle kellerräume dass das
immer so quasi bei uns die a karte am
tag wäre dann quasi runter in den keller
muss und dann geht es hier um
verständnis bei unseren zuschauern zum
beispiel hierfür auf youtube wenn sich
mal politiker zu 10 cent wenn sich nicht
mal politiker zu zehnt nicht treffen
können
dann schließt auch die schulen in denen
über 200 menschen sich sehen oder ein
anderer kommentar auf youtube hauptsache
man darf sich nur mit maximal zwei
haushalten treffen jetzt quasi in der
privat zeit aber in der schule sind es
20 bis 30 haushalte das ist ja doch
schon irgendwie ein paradox was ist
irgendwie schwierig ist vielen leuten
begreifbar zu machen oder wie würden sie
das versuchen zu erklären
also ich denke man gesteht dort den
schulen aus gutem grund auch eine
gewisse sonderrolle zu weil wir doch
auch wissen wie wichtig bildung ist für
die kinder und was wir auf anderer seite
auch für nebenwirkungen war sie hätten
wenn wir die schulen schließen das
betreffe alle berufstätigen eltern die
dann häufig eben ein betreuungsproblem
hätten die nicht arbeiten gehen könnten
das betreffe auch viele personen die
auch im gesundheitssektor arbeiten die
intensiv schwestern die ärzte die wir
jetzt ganz dringend brauchen auf den
stationen die dann gegebenfalls zu hause
bleiben müssten um ihre kinder zu
betreuen das ist halt doch ein ganz
großer umfang den mann damit betrachten
muss das ist das eine aber ich finde
auch das ist richtig wäre eben dann an
den schulen auch diese schutzmaßnahmen
tatsächlich jetzt zu intensivieren wenn
wir sehen dass es so viele fälle in der
bevölkerung gibt also in dem hinblick
was sie sagten dass eben masken pflicht
jetzt wohl verstärkt wird das finde ich
eine gute maßnahme auch an der schule
dann reden wir doch mal bei die masten
pflicht hier gibt es auch dazu
unterschiedliche stimmen ich habe das
schon eine gelesen ich muss noch mal
kurz suchen von einem schüler oder doch
einem schüler genau von simon auf
youtube der sagt warum maske ich krieg
in der schule immer kopfweh keiner fragt
uns wie es uns damit geht also das ist
tatsächlich eine beschwerde die wir ein
häufiger hört man der tochter hat sich
auch schon beschwert 56 stunden maske am
stück das ist ganz schön hart
wir haben damals den sprecher der
landesschule also der schülersprecher so
heißt das landesschülersprecher von
hessen dazu gefragt denn es die post die
was er von den maßnahmen zum beispiel
von der masten pflicht hält also das ist
natürlich was das haben wir am anfang
kritisiert weil wir eben gesagt haben so
eine maske stört stört den unterricht ja
ich meine schüler die leiseren lehrer
die leise reden um die ganze
kommunikation über mimik geht verloren
und das halte ich was das ist für den
unterricht auch extrem wichtig das heißt
so eine maske beeinträchtigt den
unterricht eindeutig und das ist auch
immer noch so und deswegen sagen auch
wenn man muss halt mit maß an setzten
aber klar ist natürlich auch eine maske
muss getragen werden wenn dadurch der
ganze präsenzunterricht aufrechterhalten
werden kann und das ist dann natürlich
ein punkt wo wir sagen okay das ist ein
übel aber da muss man mit genannt der
stelle
tja das ist übrigens mit gehen muss sagt
der landesschülersprecher von hessen
wenn es die post aber geht es nicht noch
andere maßnahmen wir haben ja auch schon
diskutiert wie über luftfilter zum
beispiel die ja doch sehr zögerlich an
geschafft und eingesetzt werden was der
hintergrund ist können wir gerade nicht
klären aber wir können versuchen zu
klären ob das nicht eine alternativ
maßnahme wäre was meinen sie frau dr
also ich denke dass das anbringen von
luftfilter geräten in den räumen selbst
eine maske nicht ersetzen wird
effektiver ist es ja tatsächlich die
räume frisch zu belüften dass es hilft
viel besser als werden wir jetzt bloß
die luft die in dem raum ist durch
irgendwelche filter schicken
also wenn dann müsste man gucken dass
vor allen dingen in den schulen wo sich
die fenster nicht abzustoßen lüften
komplett öffnen lassen dass man dort
abluft ja einmal anlagen gebaut wo man
eben diese verbrauchte luft wirklich
nach draußen bringt und dann frische zu
luft von außen wieder einbringt in die
räumlichkeiten dass wir sicherlich viel
sinnvoller als jetzt nur in der halb des
raumes die luft zu filtern
aber das wäre was man hätte im sommer
hätte machen müssen wahrscheinlich und
nicht jetzt im herbst und winter während
der unterricht läuft oder das mag alles
sein aber wichtig ist dass man es dann
jetzt macht also man kann ja immer sagen
er hätte es auch früher machen können
aber wenn dann muss man jetzt
auch mal anfangen solche sachen zu
installieren denke das wäre schon
sinnvoll
es gibt ja auch noch die möglichkeit der
klasseneinteilung die auch diskutiert
wird
das ist den bundesländern jetzt quasi
vorbehalten das zu entscheidend für sich
entweder die klassen aufzuteilen dass
ein anteil an einem tag kommt und der
andere teil am anderen tag das gab es ja
teilweise auch schon
wir haben mal den leiter des
gesundheitsamtes frankfurts rené
gottschalk gefragt was er davon hält
ich finde das für frankfurt dafür kann
ich ja auch nur sprechen weil ich die
zahlen da kenne auch völlig unnötig
eine teilung der klassen dafür besteht
infekt so logisch überhaupt keinen grund
ich würde dafür plädieren dass kinder
einen mundschutz aufsetzen dann wäre die
sache sowieso erledigt ist es
tatsächlich so einfach einfach
mundschutz auf und die sache ist
erledigt das hilft mit sicherheit sehr
sehr gut wenn alle tatsächlich
kontinuierlich diesen mund nasen schutz
tragen wird dass die infektionen
drastisch senken die wir sonst
vielleicht sehen würden
das teilen der klassen ich denke das
wäre dann sinnvoll wenn wir uns nicht
mehr zutrauen sollten über die
gesundheitsämter dann tatsächlich dort
zeitnah zu agieren in den schulen also
wenn es so weit käme dass wir sagen das
gesundheitsamt hat nicht ausreichend
personal um zeitnah in der schule zu
sein um zeitnah zu analysieren wie genau
waren dort kontakte und dann die
richtigen massnahmen anzuordnen und man
das vielleicht verschiebt auf die seite
der schulleiter oder ähnliches dass die
reagieren sollen dann kann man sozusagen
erstmal noch von dem teil der klassen
vielleicht sogar absehen aber wenn wenn
es so ist dass der schulleiter ganz
schnell entscheiden soll was mache ich
denn nun mit den schülern die mit dem
vielleicht infizierten in allen raum
gewesen sind dann bleibt dem
wahrscheinlich nur eine lösung die
radikal und kurzfristig umsetzbar wäre
und das würde bedeuten alle gehen bitte
in quarantäne erstmal nach hause bis ich
irgendeine antwort vom gesundheitsamt
habe aber das ist ja häufig und an der
stelle wäre es natürlich schön
also wir haben schon mit mitschülern
gesprochen hier im zdf die sagten zum
beispiel in berlin ja das gesundheitsamt
hat alles an mich übergeben ich muss
selber entscheiden ich muss
die kontakt verfolgung so war sogar
übernehmen für das gesundheitsamt weil
sie einfach nicht mehr weil die nicht
mehr genug kapazitäten haben das ist ja
doch auch eine ziemlich große
verantwortung für menschen die
eigentlich damit nichts zu tun haben und
auf der anderen seite habe ich hier auch
kommentare gerade gelesen von von
zuschauer zuschauerin die sagte also bei
uns wurde nur der sitznachbarin
quarantäne geschickt und sonst gar nicht
ich habe auch schon gehört dass
überhaupt niemanden quarantäne geschickt
wurde also das scheint ja doch ein
ziemliches kuddelmuddel zu herrschen da
draußen oder das ist halt die frage also
ich denke wenn der fachpersonal vor ort
ist vom gesundheitsamt was tatsächlich
einschätzen kann wie ist die situation
in der schule wer hat tatsächlich wien
getroffen wer hatte warnen mund
nasenschutz auf vivaldi belüftungs
situation wie viel zeit ist vergangen in
den räumlichkeiten gemeinsam das sind ja
alles fragen die das gesundheitsamt
stellt und dann auch für sich bewertet
und fachpersonal vom gesundheitsamt kann
das auch sehr gut und schulleiter kann
es sicherlich nicht und den muss ich
dann einfache maßnahmen an die hand
geben wie gesagt zum beispiel schicker
alle nach hause wenn sowas auftritt und
dann wäre es doch schön wenn man sagen
könnte ich schicke nur die halbe klasse
nach hause weil die mit der anderen
hälfte nie kontakt hatte
das wäre sozusagen denke ich der der
blickwinkel waren auch 1000 klassen
teilung tatsächlich sehr sinnvoll sein
könnten und ansonsten ist es ja immer
die schwierigkeit was mache ich dann
wenn ich eine geteilte klasse habe ist
die andere dann zu hause habe ich einen
ausweichraum wo ich dir einsetzen kann
oder vor allen dingen habe ich dann auch
eine person die die kinder
beaufsichtigen oder gar tatsächlich als
lehrer den zur verfügung stehen kann das
ist ja auch noch mal eine schwierigkeit
die ich habe wenn ich klassen teile
schulleiter möchte man derzeit wirklich
nicht sein
ich habe hier noch ein paar fragen
einmal zur massenblätter einen kommentar
von chris auf youtube der sagt also ich
finde die massen fließt sehr wichtig ich
schreibe ihm früher mein abitur heute an
dieser stelle ich möchte nicht noch mal
ein schulausfall kann ich gut verstehen
nur weil leute keine lust haben eine
maske aufzuziehen dann aber auch die
frage auf youtube sind masten
gesundheitsschädlich für kinder können
sie da eine antwort darauf geben
also da gibt es ja tatsächlich auch
untersuchungen zu die sagen dass das
kein gesundheitsschädigung ist wenn man
kontinuierlich maske trägt es ist so
dass man unter umständen eben ein
bisschen weniger sauerstoff aufnimmt
weil man mehr eigene ausatemluft wieder
1 atmet aber gesundheitsschädlich in dem
sinne sind sie nicht nein
so und jetzt haben wir noch einen
kommentar zu den berufsschulen die
natürlich auch betroffen sind davon hier
ist an eine e mail bekommen natürlich
müssen schulen für kinder auf und
bleiben aber warum dürfen schulen die
berufsschulen die die nötige technik für
distanz oder hybrid unterricht haben
dies nicht durchführen
ich glaube fast dass das eine frage die
weder ich beantworten kann noch sie frau
doktor pietsch oder das ist eher eine
politische frage
das ist mit sicherheit eine politische
frage ich glaube da würden wir auch mehr
gewinnen wenn wir da noch mal
tatsächlich was die masken pflicht und
das kontinuierliche tragen von masken
auch in pausenzeiten auch dann wenn wir
die schule offiziell vorbei ist vor vom
tor sozusagen wenn man da noch mal ein
bisschen nachschärfen könnte glaube ich
würden wir da als auch mehr gewinnen an
der stelle
hier geht es noch einen kommentar
vielleicht kommen wir auf meinem
bildschirm mal kurz halten auf youtube
von ns viele tkt cast warum wird nichts
gegen die schüler getan die sich nicht
an die regeln halten oder sogar lehrer
und das habe ich auch schon ähnlich auf
facebook gerade gelesen dass sich
zuschauer in beschwert haben ja schön
dass es massen fließt gibt aber guck mal
an die schulen niemand hält sich dran
da haben wir aber tatsächlich relativ
wenig handhabe gegen roger
da muss man nur appellieren und
kontrollierten handel abonnieren es
immer gut ich glaube handhabe hätte
schon der schulleiter beispielsweise
dass er dienstvorgesetzter gegenüber den
lehrern und das landes schulamt hätte
sicherlich auch möglichkeiten dort tätig
zu werden wenn es das möchte wenn
natürlich das auch erstmal darüber
informiert wäre man muss dann natürlich
auch immer wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
mit augenmaß herangehen ich nicht jede
situation ist mit der anderen
vergleichbar
das kann ich jetzt auch schwer
einschätzen was da in einzelnen
situationen gewesen ist und was da
rechtlich auch möglich wäre aber ich
denke es wäre richtig was möglich wenn
es im zusammenhang zumindest was die
lehrer betrifft
so jetzt geht es hier noch eine sache
zum lüften das ist auch an immer wieder
geäußerter kritikpunkt die das lüften in
den klassen alle 20 minuten sodass er
gemacht werden führt natürlich dazu dass
in den klassen kalt ist petra müller
schreibt mein kind und ich sind dauer
krank wie geht es weiter mit der lüfter
rey gibt es dann eine alternative
frau doktor pietsch wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr es sei denn man hat diese
lüftungsgeräte eine richtige alternative
gibt es dazu nicht wir wissen dass es
tatsächlich am besten hilft diese
aerosole diese fein schwebenden
feuchtigkeit partikel aus der luft raus
zu kriegen im klassenraum das heißt drei
mal pro stunde ist das ja empfohlen dass
man das tut und dann kann man 99
irgendwas prozent von diesen euro so und
tatsächlich aus dem klassenraum auch gut
entfernen
dass man deshalb jetzt ständig krank
wird das wäre tatsächlich aber auch im
einzelfall zu prüfen das ist eigentlich
aus medizinischer sicht so nicht
nachvollziehbar warum das so sein sollte
sicherlich muss man sich ein bisschen
von der kleidung anpassen an die
situation eine strickjacke mit haben die
gegebenenfalls in der situation
überziehen aber es ist nicht
nachzuvollziehen warum man davon jetzt
schwer krank oder dauer krank sein
sollte ich habe letztens gelernt dass
sich viren bei kalter luft besser fall
so dass das gut ist für sie weil nicht
so viel da die schleimhäute trockener
sind und also ist es irgendwie der grund
gewesen ob ich es mir richtig gemerkt
also dass man quasi deswegen im winter
er krank wird weil es eine für die viren
günstige situation ist da gibt es
verschiedene punkte warum das bei man
sich bei kalter luft leichter häufiger
infiziert das hat etwas damit auch zu
tun dass schleimhäute austrocknen können
dass man dort eintrittspforten hat in
dem bereich und die abwehrmechanismen
über die flimmerhärchen nicht richtig
funktionieren auch die zellen an der
schleimhaut oberfläche sind ausgekühlt
und können sich vielleicht ein bisschen
schlechter wären gegen die eindringenden
wären es hat auch was damit zu tun dass
die viren als solche in der kalten luft
länger infektiös bleiben es hat auch was
damit zu tun dass der euro zone sich der
länger
halten also es gibt ganz ganz viele
verschiedene kleine puzzleteile warum
wir uns in den wintermonaten insgesamt
häufiger mit solchen respiratorischen
infektionen sozusagen rumschlagen müssen
so ich habe mir noch mal 2 kommentare
auf youtube die ich gerne zeigen würde
wird dann noch mal auf dem bildschirm
liebe kollegen einmal väter geändert es
heißt dass wir permanent maske tragen
würden und dann wird alles gut werden
aber hier in bayern haben wir doch nun
genau das den letzten wochen getan sogar
in grundschulen und es war ja nicht
genug was ist denn da die erklärung
früher frau doktor kitsch gibt es eine
erklärung führen da kann man sagen dass
ja noch einmal gekommen bin ja keine
erstens weiß ich nicht ob wirklich
überall kontinuierlich welche getragen
wurden
irgendwie weiß ich das jetzt bis auf die
schulen bezieht die aussage oder auch
auf dem privaten bereich beim treffen am
nachmittag und so weiter also wir wissen
dass wir kontinuierlich alle mund nasen
schutz tragen würden dass das
tatsächlich zu einer signifikanten
absenkung der infektions
wahrscheinlichkeit führt richtig ist
dass die nicht auf null sinkt auf null
sinkt diese infektions
wahrscheinlichkeit nur wenn
sozialkontakt nie stattgefunden hat dann
sind wir bei null aber wir können mit
den masken viel erreichen und von daher
würde ich auf jeden fall ist für
notwendig erachten dass wir weiterhin
und wahrscheinlich noch mehr als vorher
auch mund nasen schutz tragen dass wir
sind noch mal zwei interessante
kommentare auf youtube einmal von lukas
music bei uns gibt es jede woche drei
neue infizierte heißt durchgängig 300
personen in quarantäne weil die hälfte
vom unterricht fällt aus oder wird
vertreten wie sinnvoll ist ist dass
unsere schule offen bleibt ja das ist
eine frage die können wir dazu nicht
beantworten aber nehmen wir mal das
kommentar hin und vielleicht noch mal
auf den rechner schalten die wir
kollegen darunter die der kommentar
wunderbar diese aussage ich kenne lehrer
die verbieten jacken im unterricht egal
wie kalt es ist da draußen und man in
der pause dann friert also da glaube ich
kann man einfach mal appellieren an die
ganzen lehrerinnen und lehrer bitte
lasst doch die kinder das ansehen was
sie möchten damit sie nicht frieren
ich hatte aber noch eine frage
abschließend an unsere virologin frau
doktor pietsch wenn wir jetzt auf
weihnachten gucken mit welchem guten
oder schlechten gewissen kann man die
familie zusammenbringen und zum beispiel
auch dann die kinder die in schulen
kindergärten gehen mit den großeltern
zusammenführen
ja das ist natürlich immer eine
ermessensfrage
eine abwägung die man da machen muss
auch das hat mit biss bei jeder familie
auch unterschiedlich wie wichtig das ist
für ein
ich denke wenn man zuvor sich
tatsächlich und so ne art selbst
quarantäne begeben hat hat man bessere
chance als wenn man das nicht tut dass
man sich treffen kann man sollte sich
auf jeden fall nicht treffen wenn
irgendeiner von den beteiligten der
respiratorische symptome hat also
erkältungssymptome hat dann sollte man
sich tunlichst nicht treffen
und ansonsten muss man das einfach ganz
offen miteinander besprechen in jeder
familie
inwieweit man da gemeinsam risiken
eingeht weil ein restrisiko wird immer
bleiben wenn man einander trifft das
liegt in der natur der sache
leider das ist wohl so ich danke ihnen
frau drb show heute abend zeit wir uns
hatten und uns rede und antwort
gestanden sind
danke euch auch für eure fragen und
kommentare
und ich hoffe wir bleiben alle so weit
es geht gesund und munter und sehen uns
bald wieder in diesem sinne macht's gut
und schießen